[Music]
on this sunday night crews in
flood-ravaged bc race to repair and
prepare
water recedes in some areas but more
rain is on the horizon as hundreds of
troops arrive to help the efforts of the
canadian armed forces and their partners
will remain vital
special delivery the first covit 19
vaccines for children arrive in canada
just as health officials warn of rising
postcovid complications in kids
and a curator for climate change every
collection in the rom
is up to me to interpret how an ontario
museum is looking to the future and our
impact on the planet
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight jeff semple
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with more bad news for
british columbia that province is set to
see more heavy rain this week even as
crews scramble to repair the damage from
last week's rainfall by the end of today
more than 500 canadian forces personnel
will be on the ground in bc assisting
with evacuations rescuing livestock and
helping to protect critical
infrastructure and that help is
desperately needed in the city of
abbotsford which is now racing to build
up dikes ahead of that severe weather
expected in the coming days our mike
armstrong is monitoring the situation in
abbotsford for us tonight where
officials have just provided an update
mike
yeah we've heard from the mayor who says
this actually could have been much much
worse he said that the city came very
close to losing the vital barrow town
pumping station monday as for the
situation today he confirms the
floodgates are now fully open the dyke
system is repaired enough that water is
no longer coming through and the pumping
station is working at full capacity we
spent the day driving around the region
to see what that means to people on the
ground
there was literally like white caps here
it was raging so fast her street she
says was unrecognizable denise krins
says between firefighters telling her to
leave and the water rising there were
only minutes the escape monday was done
she says in panic mode we had animals to
take care of two kids
it was really frantic we forgot a lot of
stuff look it took the tracks right out
the water has receded in this
neighborhood leaving behind it a path of
destruction it has also left behind some
difficult memories one of clayton
liscombe's colleagues at this business
shot video as the water came in
i am totally stranded at work i'm
freaking real i wish i could show you
guys how really really bad all this is
came up pretty quick because they were
doing one thing and they said murray
said
well a buddy of mine that works here he
said it came up like within
20 minutes it was up to his waist pretty
much so now the return to normal life is
further the lower you get for these two
men home is a place still surrounded by
water a brother-in-law is the only
person who's been back he walked in hip
waiters to help pets that were left
behind on top of the damage to their
home they've lost trucks cars a tractor
and other vehicles they all under about
like they
they like you know right right now
they're done they are ride offs
off in the distance crews repairing the
main breach in the dyke truck after
truck dumping gravel this is what that
looked like from the air the city of
abbotsford sharing video of the work on
the ground
it has also shared photos of what is a
growing military presence by the end of
the day more than 500 troops will be in
bc providing support there's both a land
element and an air contingent 11
military aircraft are either in use or
on their way now this area on the map is
called sumas plain it feels more like
it's gone back to the name it used to
have this is a photo of sumas lake taken
just over a hundred years ago before the
dikes were built and before the lake was
drained
for some the thought that this could
happen was there but it felt as though
it wasn't something to worry about
oh yeah we do we know it's a flood plain
but yeah you don't expect it really
driving around the region there are more
roads open today than yesterday not all
of them this is the trans-canada highway
behind me where it's closed but we did
come upon spots that were under water 24
hours ago that are dry today
that said a lot of these roads as the
water recedes now need extensive repairs
jeff
mike armstrong reporting for us from
abbotsford bc thanks mike
today's weather is cooperating with
those rebuilding efforts for now but
that forecast could take a turn for the
worse as early as tomorrow and for more
on what to expect this week let's go now
to global news meteorologist yvonne
shell jeff a significant amount of rain
and windy conditions all courtesy of an
atmospheric river takes aim along the
north and central coast through the
afternoon and evening flood watch
especially for areas near stuart the big
concern inland a significant amount of
snow changing over to rain we've seen
some freezing rain across the region but
the drainage systems may be blocked or
overwhelmed prince rupert and haida guy
also included within the flood watch
inland areas with up to 80 millimeters
of rain along the coast 90 but the winds
ramp up continuing towards monday gusts
between 90 and potentially up to 110
kilometers per hour this system will
work its way along the south coast the
concern up to 20 millimeters not a
significant amount of rain but it'll
exasperate the flooding situation along
the south coast and then a look ahead
we've got a series of systems and the
big concern to watch out for will be on
thursday where we are looking at a
significant fall storm that'll take aim
along the south coast and we could see
additional rainfall amounts anywhere
between 50 and up to 100 millimeters
jeff
thanks yvonne
the city of merit about 90 minutes
northeast of abbotsford has also been
hit hard by that flooding take a look at
this new video from helicopter pilot
bradley friesen that reveals the
destruction along highway 8 that's just
north of merit bc's ministry of
transportation says more than 40
kilometers of highway was washed away by
the raging flood waters
the city of merit itself also suffered
extensive damage its more than seven
thousand residents were ordered to
evacuate after the wastewater treatment
plant failed on monday the mayor says
work is now underway to repair the
facility officials are also working to
determine which areas of the city will
be safe for residents to return
to other news now and canada's 44th
parliament will convene for the first
time on monday and there was plenty on
the agenda to occupy the new government
and our chief political correspondent
david aiken who joins us now from ottawa
so david the government will set out its
agenda in the speech from the throne on
tuesday what should we expect
there is plenty on the agenda jeff the
situation in bc of course will be the
immediate focus but what you will hear
from the trudeau government is a plan to
first of all deal with covet 19 and then
second to put in place plans for an
economic recovery
in fact a new poll done exclusively for
global news by ipsos shows that
inflation and the rapid rise in the cost
of groceries and gas is the top issue
that voters want the government to
tackle for canadians at the moment right
now and right right now
they're more concerned about cost of
living and affordability because it's
something that they feel every time they
go to the grocery store every time they
go online to buy something every time
they even fill up their you know their
car at the gas station they're really
feeling it when ipsos asked respondents
to name their top two issues for the
federal government 33 percent put
affordability and cost of living at the
top 27 percent listed the pandemic as
one of their top two issues health care
was right behind at 25
and 24 said housing was a priority
during the election campaign and after
prime minister justin trudeau signaled
that his government intends to address
the housing crisis in many canadian
communities the average cost of a new
home in canada has jumped by 32 percent
in the last two years and that's put
home ownership out of reach for many
canadians trudeau has named toronto mp
ahmed hussein as his minister of housing
and the throne speech is expected to
outline some specific tasks that trudeau
will have for hussein what they're
seeing is a public very concerned about
what the future is going to look like
canadians will also get a sense in the
week ahead about how stable this
minority parliament will be the trudeau
liberals have been talking to jugmeet
singh and the ndp to find areas of
cooperation though singh is not prepared
to give trudeau a blank check meanwhile
the official opposition conservatives
are dealing with their own issues
including divisions in the caucus over
vaccine mandates and over the leadership
of aaron o'toole it all starts monday
with the election of the speaker for the
country's 44th parliament jeff
david aiken reporting for us from ottawa
thanks david
the first shipment of covid19 vaccine
for children arrived in canada today the
plane carrying the first pediatric doses
for kids aged 5 to 11 touching down
today at hamilton international airport
the pfizer biontech vaccine for children
was approved friday by health canada
it's a smaller dose than the adult
version and the regulator says that it
is about 91 percent effective in
preventing covid19 in kids while
producing no serious side effects the
first canadian shipment comes about two
weeks after the vaccine was approved for
use in children in the united states
now as we know children have a lower
risk of becoming seriously ill from
covid19 but doctors in alberta are
seeing an increase in children
hospitalized with a postcovid syndrome
known as miss c 61 cases have been
reported in that province and the
illness typically comes on about four
weeks after a covid19 infection and in
some cases children become so sick they
end up in intensive care heather urix
west reports
last month five-year-old porter nixon
spent seven days inside the alberta
children's hospital's icu
weeks earlier the calgary kindergarten
student had been infected with covid19
but with symptoms no different than the
common cold he was never tested a month
later he became sick again this time
with flu-like symptoms then a rash he
was eventually admitted to hospital
diagnosed with multi-system inflammatory
syndrome in children a post-covet
condition also known as missy
we've seen quite a large number of cases
maybe last two months almost every day
we have a child with masc in the icu and
often we have a child with covert
pneumonia as well children typically
become ill with missy four weeks after
covet infection so it makes sense that
weeks after the province saw cases of
covet 19 surge during its fourth wave
pediatric icus would be seeing more
children sick with miss c
according to alberta health there have
been 61 cases of missee in the province
since the pandemic began with 27
children admitted to intensive care this
six-year-old southern alberta boy whose
parents have asked that we don't share
his name was admitted to icu in october
as well
his mother says her son had no symptoms
of covid19 but an antibody test revealed
he had been infected with the virus
weeks later inflammation in his heart
was causing his blood pressure to drop
dangerously low
i don't think people realize that there
is a real chance your child can get sick
from covert
and
it's certainly i don't think widely
appreciated which may be why alberta's
premier says many parents are not
planning to get their children the kovid
19 vaccine we've done some public
opinion research indicating that roughly
half of parents of children in that age
range
are likely to get their kids vaccinated
so it's a much lower level of
support both alberta boys have been
released from hospital and are now
recovering at home
well there have been no deaths related
to missing in canada there have been
dozens of children hospitalized across
the country and in the u.s 48 kids have
died a rare but serious risk to children
related to covet 19.
heather urex west global news calgary
covet 19 kept americans home last
thanksgiving but this year millions are
on the move airline bookings are up more
than 100 compared to 2020 but those
travel plans may hit some turbulence
that's because starting tomorrow agents
with the transportation safety
administration or tsa are required to be
vaccinated and many are refusing
jennifer johnson has more
in the midst of the busiest travel week
since the pandemic began tsa agents are
facing a monday deadline to either get
vaccinated or face the consequences
there is the potential if you
do not have an approved exemption and
you are not vaccinated that you will
lose your job an estimated 2 million
passengers a day are passing through
america's airports for the 10 days
surrounding thanksgiving but travel
experts wanted possible delays as
thousands of tsa agents are still
refusing to get the shot travelers are
building in extra time we just know that
we have to be here earlier and
anticipate that there's going to be more
lines and things as of mid-october an
estimated 40 percent of tsa agents had
not been vaccinated the administration
hasn't provided an updated number but
says it's greatly improved whether the
unvaccinated will be immediately fired
is unclear all federal employees face
the monday deadline but the biden
administration is encouraging each
agency to investigate before terminating
we have a lot of employees who've asked
for either medical or religious
exemptions as well and so we'll go
through the process of looking at each
one of those individual cases and making
determination over the next several
weeks
vaccine mandates have already caused
thousands of pilots to leave their jobs
resulting in record numbers of flight
cancellations in the past few months
experts warn the holiday travel seasons
could be challenging this year it's
going to be a lot more difficult to
travel
than it has
prior to the covered period the vaccine
mandate comes as the centers for disease
control reports deaths from coven 19 and
2021 have now surpassed 2020's total
a quarter of eligible americans are
still not vaccinated and new cases are
rising again in 46 states
jennifer johnson global news washington
bieber boycott still ahead why the
canadian pop star is facing calls to
cancel an upcoming concert
five police officers were hurt and
dozens of protesters were detained in
another violent night in the netherlands
dutch police armed with riot shields
used water cannons and police dogs as
they tried to stop rioters who set fires
and attacked them with fireworks the
protesters are angry about government
plans to enact partial lockdowns and
tighter restrictions for the
unvaccinated
and tens of thousands of people also
took to the streets of khartoum as
sudan's military reinstated that
country's prime minister under a signed
agreement with military leaders prime
minister abdullah hamdok will head a
transitional civilian government and
political detainees will also be freed
sudan has been in a state of crisis
since its longtime ruler was overthrown
in 2019 then last month the military
seized power and launched a brutal
crackdown on protesters
canadian pop superstar justin bieber is
facing growing calls to cancel an
upcoming show in saudi arabia
[Music]
the biebs is set to perform in the red
sea city of jeddah on december the 5th
as the country hosts its first ever
formula one race but in an open letter
the fiancee of slain saudi journalist
jamal khashoggi says bieber should
cancel to send a message to the saudi
government khashoggi was killed in
istanbul in 2018 by a team of saudi
government agents linked to the saudi
crown prince mohammed bin salman
and after disappearing from public view
for nearly three weeks the international
olympic committee says the chinese
tennis star pong shui has taken part in
a 30-minute video call from beijing
concern had been growing for pong's
well-being after she made an allegation
of sexual assault against a former
member of the communist party's ruling
committee ioc president thomas bach who
was on the call says that pong said that
she is safe and is asking for her
privacy to be respected
coming up an aquatic comeback how one
endangered species is giving hope to
canada's fishing industry
canada's fishing industry generates 6
billion a year and puts food on the
table for thousands of canadians but a
new report is warning most of this
country's fish stocks are depleted or in
questionable health though there is one
popular species that's making a
remarkable comeback ross lord has the
details
the atlantic bluefin tuna is an
endangered species there are barely half
as many bluefins as there were in the
1970s but the latest stock assessment
shows the popular species is rebounding
the assessment was quite surprising for
everybody it was a big turnaround
enough for canadian officials at an
international conservation meeting in
spain to push for a 16 percent increase
in bluefin quota even hard to please
conservationists are encouraged everyone
industries scientists and government has
put a lot of work into this stock and
recognize that it's very important
and when you do that and when you stick
to the plan and when you don't go too
far out of whack you know you do see
recovery for other fish stocks like
sockeye salmon the struggle continues
according to the research group oceana
the group says the department of
fisheries and oceans is failing canada's
fisheries leaving sockeye and other
species like capelan and newfoundland
and labrador vulnerable to overfishing
and depletion only about 30 percent of
our stocks we can verify are healthy
and we have about 17 percent that are in
critical and the department hasn't put
in place rebuilding plans for those for
most of those critical stocks oceana
says the government has made big
investments in fisheries science and has
updated the fishery act but has not
followed through with new regulations
that are needed to conserve and rebuild
stocks it's a problem other researchers
are also identifying the laws and the
policies on paper
they're really good if only we could
implement them so this is usually where
the problem where the problem arises
sumila hopes the new fisheries minister
bc's joyce murray will make the
necessary changes to make success
stories like bluefin tuna the norm and
not the exception
ross lord global news
still ahead how canada's largest museum
is making history by hiring a curator of
climate change
toronto's royal ontario museum is the
largest museum in canada dedicated to
world cultures and natural history and
the rom is now making some history of
its own by focusing on the future it
just became the first major museum in
north america to hire a curator whose
only focus is climate change mike
trolley explains
the royal ontario museum's aggressively
modern facade has become something of a
tourist attraction yet it's easy to
forget how many people initially
hated it a museum it was said should be
about the past
but that notion says its ceo couldn't be
more wrong
we're an institution that looks to the
future our mission is to make sense of
the help people to make sense of the
past understand the present and come
together to shape a shared future to
that end the rom has hired its first
ever climate curator a job at soren
brothers hopes will allow him to engage
the public in ways his career and
academia couldn't it's been understood
from day one that i'm the first curator
here with no collection
but the flip side of that is that every
collection in the rom
is up to me to interpret in a way the
rom has always addressed climate impacts
in its exhibits how the dinosaurs became
extinct or more current issues like the
threat to the giant sperm whale
it's now dr brothers job to take the
conversation about climate change to the
next level
it's a timely issue evidence of global
warming from wildfires to floods isn't
hard to find and the cop 26 conference
on climate change just wrapped up with
newfound promises to cut carbon
emissions there's no question dr
brothers says climate change can be
scary fear is not a really productive
emotion and so i don't want to just
shock people or get people feeling
scared about what's happening with
climate change there's definitely a fine
line to walk there in terms of also not
losing the gravity of the situation of
gravity of the reality of it but with
climate change nothing good will happen
without first starting the conversation
mike drolite global news toronto
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm jeff semple tonight's
your canada is an episode migma trail in
northern new brunswick the picturesque
147 kilometer trail is the only canadian
destination to earn a coveted spot on
national geographic's list of the most
exciting places to visit in 2022 and
it's easy to see why thanks for watching
donna friesen will be back here at the
anchor desk tomorrow have a great night
[Music]